resentment is like drinking poison
and then hoping it will kill your
enemies
it is what we make out of what we have
not what we are given
that separates one person from another
tread Softly
breathe peacefully
laugh hysterically
we owe our children
the most vulnerable citizens in any
society
a life free from violence and fear
education is the most powerful weapon
which you can use to change the world
I learned that courage was not the
absence of fear but the triumph over it
the brave man is not he who does not
feel afraid
but he who conquers that fear
when a man is denied the right to live
the life he believes in
he has no choice but to become an outlaw
there were many dark moments when my
faith in humanity was sorely tested
but I would not and could not give
myself up to despair
that way Lay's defeat and death
a good head and good heart are always a
formidable combination
but when you add to that illiterate
tongue or pen
then you have something very special
it always seems impossible until it's
done
I am fundamentally an optimist whether
that comes from nature or nurture I
cannot say
part of being optimistic is keeping
one's head pointed toward the Sun
one's feet moving forward
no one is born hating another person
because of the color of his skin or his
background or his religion
people must learn to hate
and if they can learn to hate
they can be taught to love
to be free is not merely to cast off
one's chains
but to live in a way that respects and
enhances the freedom of others
there is nothing like returning to a
place that remains unchanged
to find the ways in which you yourself
have altered
do not judge me by my successes
Judge Me by how many times I fell down
and got back up
lead from the back
and let others believe they are in front
I am not a saint unless you think of a
saint as a sinner who keeps on trying
there is no passion to be found playing
small
and settling for a life that is less
than one you are capable of living
if you talk to a man in a language he
understands
that goes to his head
if you talk to him in his language
that goes to his heart
you can never have an impact on society
if you have not changed yourself
great peacemakers are all people of
Integrity of honesty
but humility
overcoming poverty is not a task of
charity
it is an act of Justice
as we let our own light shine we
unconsciously give other people
permission to do the same
it is said that no one truly knows a
nation
until one has been inside its jails
a nation should not be judged by how it
treats its highest citizens but its
lowest ones
may your choices reflect your hopes
not your fears
a winner is a dreamer who never gives up
where you stand depends on where you sit
one of the things I learned when I was
negotiating was that until I changed
myself
I could not change others
appearances matter
and remember to smile
[Music]
after climbing a great Hill
one only finds that there are many more
Hills to climb
live life as though nobody is watching
and express yourself as though everyone
is listening
one cannot be prepared for something
while secretly believing it will not
happen
nothing is Black or White
and my country we go to prison first and
then become president
know your enemy and learn about his
favorite sport
it is not where you start but how high
you aim that matters for success
sometimes it falls upon a generation to
be great
you can be that generation
without language
one cannot talk to people and understand
them
one cannot share their hopes and
aspirations
grasp their history
appreciate their poetry
or Savor their songs
Let There Be justice for all
let there be peace for all
Let There Be work bread water and salt
for all
Let each know that for each the body the
mind and the Soul have been free to
fulfill themselves
quitting is leading to
we must use time creatively
and forever realize that the time is
always ripe to do right
when the water starts boiling
it is foolish to turn off the heat
if a man thinks badly of you then he is
worse than you
those who are better than you
just don't care about you
a person does not become a freedom
fighter in the hope of winning Awards
one sign of mutual friendship is the
enjoyment of communication
peace is the greatest weapon for
development that any person can have
to find out if your friend is loyal
ask him to lie to another friend
it is music and dancing that make me at
peace with the world
no single person can liberate a country
you can only liberate a country if you
act as a collective
only free men can negotiate
prisoners can't enter in contracts
there are a few misfortunes in this
world that you cannot turn into a
personal Triumph if you have the Iron
Will and the necessary skill
courageous people do not fear forgiving
for the sake of peace